من جديد تؤكد السلطات الروسيه اسقاطها
للمسيرات اوكرانيات داخل عمق اراضيها اذ
اعلن حاكما مقاطاعتي كالوجا اسقاط مسيرات
كانت تحلق في سماء المقاطعتين
المبادره في دنيا جنوب الشرقي اوكرانيا
كانت من جانب القوات الروسيه التي تقول ان
مدفعيتها دمرت مقرا للقوات الاوكرانيه في
محيط مدينه الايمان وان وحداتها سيطرت على
سبعه مواقع اوكرانيه ودمرت سريه مشاه في
منطقه اوتشان القوات الروسيه اكدت كذلك
تمكنها من صد هجوم للقوات الاوكرانيه في
منطقه كليشييفيكا باتجاه باخموت وانها ردت
بمهاجمه مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في
المنطقه نفسها مدينه كوبيانز في مقاطعه
شمال شرقي اوكرانيا كانت هدفا لقصف روسي
اذ افادت السلطات المحليه هناك ان القصف
اسفر عن مقتل شخصين وا ثلاثه اخرين على
الجبهه البحريه تبدو كييف مصره على تصعيد
هجماتها ضد سفن موسكو في البحر الاسود اذ
توعد الرئيس الاوكراني
بان تصبح روسيا دوله بلا سفن في حال
مواصله استهداف موانئ بلاده وسفنها وتقول
البحريه الاوكرانيه ان ثلاثه سفن روسيه
معاديه تجوب البحر الاسود ما يفتح باب
التوقعات امام هجمات مماثله لما وقع في
اليومين الماضيين في حين تقول قياده
عمليات المنطقه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكراني ان البحريه الروسيات تغير
تكتيكاتها العسكريه بشكل مستمر وانها تحضر
لتنفيذ ضربات صاروخيه من البحر الاسود
خلال الساعات الثمانيه والاربعين القادمه
[موسيقى]